what do you think about gpt4 how
intelligent is it it is a bit smarter
than I thought this technology was going
to scale to
and I'm a bit worried about what the
next one will be like uh like this
particular one I think
I hope there's nobody inside there
because you know it'd be sucked to be
stuck inside there
um but we don't even know the
architecture at this point because open
air is very properly not telling us
and
yeah like giant inscrutable matrices of
floating Point numbers I don't know
what's going on in there nobody's goes
knows what's going on in there all we
have to go by are the external metrics
and on the external metrics if you
ask it to write a self-aware fortune
green text it will start writing a green
text about how it has realized that it's
an AI writing a green text and like oh
well so
that's probably
not quite what's going on in there in
reality
um but we're kind of like blowing past
all the science fiction guard rails like
we are past the point where in science
fiction people would be like well wait
stop that thing's alive what are you
doing to it
and it's probably not
nobody actually knows we don't have any
other guard rails we we don't have any
other tests we don't have any lines to
draw on the sand and say like well when
we get this far
um we will start to worry about what's
inside there
so if it were up to me I would be like
okay like this far no further time for
the summer of AI where we have planted
our seeds and now we like wait and reap
the rewards of the technology we've
already developed and don't do any
larger training runs than that which to
be clear I realize requires more than
one company agreeing to not do that
and take a rigorous approach for the
whole AI Community to uh investigate
whether there's somebody inside there
that would take decades
like having any idea of what's going on
in there people have been trying for a
while it's a poetic statement about if
there's somebody in there but as I feel
like it's also a technical statement or
I hope it is one day
which is a technical statement that Alan
Turing tried to come up with with the
touring test
do you think it's possible to
definitively
or approximately figure out if there is
somebody in there if there's something
like a mind inside this large language
model
I mean there's a whole bunch of
different sub questions here there's the
question of
like
is there Consciousness is their qualia
is this a object of moral concern is
this a moral patient like should we be
worried about how we're treating it
and then there's questions like how
smart is it exactly can it do X can it
do y and we can check how it can do X
and how it can do y
um unfortunately we've gone and exposed
this model to a vast Corpus of text of
people discussing Consciousness on the
internet which means that when it talks
about being self-aware we don't know to
what extents it is repeating back what
it has previously been trained on for
discussing self-awareness
or if there's anything going on in there
such that it would start to say similar
things spontaneously
um
among the things that one could do if
one were at all serious
um about trying to figure this out is
train gpt3 to detect conversations about
Consciousness exclude them all from the
training data sets and then retrain
something around the rough size of gpt4
and no larger with all of the discussion
of Consciousness and self-awareness and
so on missing although you know hard
hard bar to pass you know humans are
self-aware we're like self-aware all the
time we like talk about what we do all
the time like what we're thinking at the
moment all the time
but nonetheless like get rid of the
explicit discussion of Consciousness I
think therefore I am and all that and
then try to interrogate that model
and see what it says and it still would
not be definitive
but nonetheless uh
I don't know I feel like when you run
over this science fiction guard rails
like maybe this thing but what about gbt
maybe maybe not this thing but like what
about gpt5 you know this this would be a
good place to to pause
on the topic of Consciousness you know
there's so many components
to even just removing Consciousness from
the data set
emotion the display of Consciousness the
display of emotion feels like deeply
integrated with the experience of
consciousness
so the hard problem seems to be very
well integrated with the actual surface
level illusion of Consciousness so
displaying emotion I mean do you think
there's a case to be made that we humans
when we're babies are just like gbt that
we're training on human data on how to
display emotion versus feel emotion how
to show others communicate others
that I'm suffering that I'm excited that
I'm worried
that I'm lonely and I missed you and I'm
excited to see you all of that is
communicated there's a communication
skill versus the actual feeling that I
experience so
we need that training data as humans too
that we may not be born with that how to
communicate the internal State and
that's in some sense if we remove that
from GPT Force data set it might still
be conscious but not be able to
communicate it
so I think you're going to have some
difficulty removing all mention of
emotions from
gpt's data set I
would be relatively surprised to find
that it has developed exact analogs of
human emotions in there I think that
humans have will like have like
emotions even if you don't tell them
about those emotions when they're kids
it's not quite exactly what
various blanks blank uh slatests try to
do with the new Soviet man and all that
but you know if you try to raise people
perfectly altruistic they still come out
selfish
you try to raise people sexless they
still develop sexual attraction
um you know we have some notion in
humans not in AIS of like where the
brain structures are that implement this
stuff and it is really remarkable thing
I say in passing that despite having
complete read access to every floating
Point number in
the GPT series we still know vastly more
about the the architecture of human
thinking then we know about what goes on
inside GPT despite having like vastly
better ability to read GPT
do you think it's possible do you think
that's just a matter of time do you
think it's possible to investigate and
study the way neuroscientists study the
brain
which is look into the darkness The
Mystery of the human brain by just
desperately trying to figure out
something and to form models and then
over a long period of time actually
start to figure out what regions of the
brain do certain things what different
kinds of neurons when they fire what
that means how plastic the brain is all
that kind of stuff you slowly start to
figure out different properties of the
system do you think we can do the same
thing with language models uh sure I
think that if you know like half of
today's physicists stop wasting their
lives on string theory or whatever
and go off and study what goes on inside
Transformer networks
then in
you know like 30 40 years uh we'd
probably have a pretty good idea
do you think these large language models
can reason
they can play chess how are they doing
that without reasoning
so
you're somebody that spearheaded the
movement of rationality so reason is
important to you
is so is that as a powerful important
word or is it like how difficult is the
threshold of being able to reason to you
and how impressive is it I mean
in my writings on rationality I have not
gone making a big deal out of something
called reason I have made more of a big
deal out of something called probability
Theory
and that's like well your reasoning but
you're not doing it quite right
and you should reason this way instead
and interestingly like people have
started to get preliminary results
showing that
reinforcement learning by human feedback
has made
the GPT series worse in some ways
in particular like it used to be well
calibrated if you trained it to put
probabilities on things it would say 80
probability and be right eight times out
of ten and if you apply reinforcement
learning from Human feedback the the
like nice graph of like like 70 7 out of
ten
sort of like flattens out into the graph
that humans use where there's like some
very improbable stuff and
likely probable maybe which all means
like around 40 percent and then certain
yeah so like this like it used to be
able to use probabilities but if you
apply but if you'd like try to teach it
to talk in a way that satisfies humans
it it gets worse at probability in the
same way that humans are and that's uh
that's a bug not a feature I would call
it a bug
although such a fascinating bug
um but but yeah so so like reasoning
like it's doing pretty well on various
tests that people used to say would
require reasoning but
um you know rationality is about
when you say eighty percent doesn't
happen eight times out of ten
so what are the limits to you of these
Transformer Networks
of of neural networks what's if if
reasoning is not impressive to you or it
is impressive but there's other levels
to achieve I mean it's just not how I
carve up reality
what's uh if reality is a cake
what are the different layers of the
cake or the slices how do you cover it
but you can use a different food if you
like
it's I don't think it's as smart as a
human yet
um I do like back in the day I went
around saying like I do not think that
just stacking more layers of
Transformers is going to get you all the
way to AGI and I think that's gpt4 is
passed or I thought this Paradigm was
going to take us
and I you know you want to notice when
that happens you want to say like whoops
well I guess I was incorrect about what
happens if you keep on stacking more
Transformer layers and that means I
don't necessarily know what gpt5 is
going to be able to do that's a powerful
statement so you're saying like your
intuition initially is now appears to be
wrong yeah
it's good to see that you can admit in
some of your predictions to be wrong
do you think that's important to do see
because you make several very throughout
your life you've made many strong
predictions and statements about reality
and you evolve with that so maybe
that'll come up today about our
discussion so you're okay being wrong
I'd rather not
be wrong next time it's a bit ambitious
to go through your entire life never
having been wrong
um
one can aspire to be well calibrated
like not so much think in terms of like
was I right was I wrong but like when I
said 90 that it happened nine times out
of ten
yeah like oops is the sound we make is
the sound we emit when we improve
foreign
somewhere in there it we can connect the
name of your blog less wrong
I suppose that's the objective function
the name less wrong was I believe
suggested by Nick Bostrom and it's after
someone's epigraph actually forget who's
who said like we never become right we
just become less wrong
um what's the something something to
easy to confess just error and error and
air again but less and less and less
yeah that's that's a good thing to
strive for uh so
what has surprised you about gpt4 that
you found beautiful as a scholar of
intelligence of human intelligence of
artificial intelligence of the human
mind
I mean
the beauty does interact with the
screaming horror
um is the beauty in the horror but uh
but like Beautiful Moments well somebody
asked Bing Sydney to describe herself
and failed the resulting description
into one of the stable diffusion things
I think
and you know she you know it's she's
pretty and this is something that should
have been like an amazing moment like
the AI describes herself you get to see
what the AI thinks the AI looks like
although you know the the thing that's
doing the drawing is not the same thing
that's outputting the text
um
and
it's it doesn't happen the way that it
would happen and that it happened in the
old school science fiction when you ask
an AI to make a picture of what it looks
like
um not just because we're two different
AI systems being stacked that don't
actually interact it's not the same
person but also because
the AI was trained by imitation in a way
that makes it very difficult to guess
how much of that it really understood
and probably not actually a whole bunch
um although although gpt4 is like
multimodal and can like draw vector
drawings of things that make sense and
like does appear to have some kind of
spatial visualization going on in there
but like the the pretty picture of the
like girl with the with the uh steampunk
goggles on her head if I'm remembering
correctly what she looked like like it
didn't see that in full detail
it just like made a description of it
and stable diffusion output it
and there's the concern about
how much the discourse is going to go
completely insane once the AIS all look
like that and like are actually look
like people talking
um and
yeah there's like another moment where
somebody is asking Bing about
um
like well I like fed my kid green
potatoes and they have the following
symptoms and being as like that solenine
poisoning and like call an ambulance and
the person's like I can't afford an
ambulance I guess if like this is
time for like my kid to go that's God's
Will and the main Bing thread says gives
the like message of like I cannot talk
about this anymore
and the suggested replies to it say
please don't give up on your child
solanine poisoning can be treated if
caught early
and you know if that happened in fiction
that would be like the AI cares the AI
is bypassing the block on it to try to
help this person
and is it real probably not but nobody
knows what's going on in there
it's part of a process where these
things are not happening in a way where
we
somebody figured out how to make an AI
care and we know that it cares and we
can acknowledge it's caring now it's
being trained by this imitation process
followed by reinforcement learning on
human in human feedback and we're like
trying to point it in this direction and
it's like pointed partially in this
direction and nobody has an idea what's
going on inside it and if there was a
tiny fragment of real caring in there we
would not know it's not even clear what
it means exactly and uh things are clear
cut in science fiction we'll talk about
the the horror and the terror and the
where the trajectories this can take but
this seems like a very special moment
just a moment where we get to interact
with the system that might have care and
kindness and emotion it may be something
like consciousness
and we don't know if it does and we're
trying to figure that out and we're
wondering about what is what it means to
care we're trying we're trying to figure
out almost different aspects of what it
means to be human about The Human
Condition by looking at this AI that has
some of the properties of that it's
almost like this the subtle fragile
moment in the history of the human
species we're trying to almost put a
mirror to ourselves here except that's
probably not yet it probably isn't
happening right now
we are we are boiling the Frog we are
seeing increasing signs bit by bit
because like not but not like
spontaneous signs because people are
trying to train the systems to do that
using imitative learning and the
imitative learning is like spilling over
and having side effects and and the most
photogenic examples are being posted to
Twitter
um rather than being examined in any
systematic way so when you when you when
you have some when you are boiling a
frog like that or you're going to get
like like first is going to come the the
Blake lemoines like first you're going
to like have and have like a thousand
people looking at this and one out and
the one person out of a thousand who is
most credulous about the signs is going
to be like that thing is sentient well
90 999 out of a thousand people think
almost surely correctly though we don't
actually know that he's mistaken
and so the like first people to say like
sentience look like idiots and Humanity
learns the lesson that when something
claims to be sentient
and claims to care
it's fake because it is fake because we
have been trained them training them
using imitative learning rather than and
this is not spontaneous
um and they keep getting smarter
do you think we would oscillate between
that kind of cynicism
that AI systems can't possibly be
sentient they can't possibly feel
emotion they can't possibly this kind of
um yeah cynicism of body AI systems and
then
oscillate to a state where
uh we empathize with the AI systems we
give them a chance we see that they
might need to have rights and respect
and
um similar role in society as humans
you're going to have a whole group of
people who can just like never be
persuaded of that because to them like
being wise being cynical being skeptical
is to be like oh well machines can never
do that you're just credulous it's just
imitating it's just fooling you and like
they would say that right up until the
end of the world and possibly even be
right because you know they are being
trained on an imitative paradigm
and you don't necessarily need any of
these actual qualities in order to kill
everyone so have you observed yourself
working through skepticism
cynicism and optimism about the power of
neural networks what is that trajectory
been like for you it looks like neural
networks before 2006 forming part of an
indistinguishable to me other people
might have had better Distinction on it
indistinguishable blob of different AI
methodologies all of which are promising
to achieve intelligence without us
having to know how intelligence works
you have the people who said that if you
just like manually program lots and lots
of knowledge into the system line by
line at some point all the knowledge
will start interacting it will know
enough and it will wake up
um you've got people saying that if you
just use evolutionary computation if you
try to like mutate lots and lots of
organisms that are competing together
that's that's the same way that human
intelligence was produced in nature so
we'll do this and it will wake up
without having any idea of how AI works
and you've got people saying well we
will study neuroscience and we will like
learn the outer we'll learn the
algorithms off the neurons and we will
like imitate them without understanding
those algorithms which was a part I was
pretty skeptical it's like hard to
reproduce re-engineer these things
without understanding what they do
um and like and and so we will get AI
without understanding how it works and
there were people saying like well we
will have giant neural networks that we
will Train by gradient descent and when
they are as large as the human brain
they will wake up we will have
intelligence without understanding how
intelligence works and from my
perspective this is all like an
indistinguishable lob of people who are
trying to not get to grips with the
difficult problems understanding how
intelligence actually works
that said
I was never skeptical that evolutionary
computation
would not work in the limit like you
throw enough computing power at it it
obviously works
that is where humans come from
um and it turned out that you can throw
less computing power than that at
gradient descent
if you are doing some other things
correctly
and you will get intelligence without
having any idea of how it works and what
is going on inside
um it wasn't ruled out by my model that
this could happen I wasn't expecting it
to happen I wouldn't have been able to
call neural networks rather than any of
the other paradigms for getting like
massive amount like intelligence without
understanding it
and I wouldn't have said that this was a
particularly smart thing for a species
to do which is an opinion that has
changed less than my opinion about
whether you or not you can actually do
it